6 14 on your Wednesday morning hey how
do you ask for a stop sign or a traffic
signal get a lot of emails about
specific intersections like this
viewer Diana writes exiting on a Decatur
from any Street between blue diamond and
Warm Springs that's like stepping out
into the wild wild west we've been
asking for a stop sign or traffic signal
at Windmill for a few years now
there's also a backup trying to get out
of blue diamond from Arville and with
only one turn lane that can take a
couple of Cycles we've been asking for a
second turn lane so Diana and anybody
having any issue with any intersection I
can't guarantee that anything will
happen however both the city of Las
Vegas and Clark County have online
services they want you to let them know
about stuff like this for links to both
of these websites you want to go to the
online version of this story at
8newsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy now I can tell you the
people using the Clark County's Fix-It
system they help get those all-way stop
signs put in at Desert Inn and theme
Road around that bridge in the Far East
Valley buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone you can join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com